[음악]
제가 오늘은
뉴욕 부동산에 대해서 좀 얘기를
해보도록 할 건데
굉장히 좀 특별한 게스트분을 좀
모셨어요
뉴욕에서 처음에 또 이제 인연이
닿았고 최근에 또 이번에 한국으로
오셨거든요 그래서 제가 어렵게 부탁을
드려서 출연하게 됐습니다
플래티넘 프라퍼티의 박진우 부사장님
모셨습니다 안녕하세요
안녕하십니까
초대해주셔서 감사합니다
개인적으로 그때 이제 뉴욕 가가지고
너무 또 잘 해주셨고
거기서도 이번에
와주셔서
꼭 나와 달라고 제가 말씀드렸는데
이렇게 출연해 주셔서 감사드리고 일단
좀 간단하게 소개 좀 한번 해주세요
저는
박진우라고 하고요 뉴욕에서 부동산을
대학을 전공을 하고 그 이후로 출고
이제 부동산 일을 해왔고요
한국에서도 여기
베이스가 있는 회사의 취사에 나와서
근무를 한 7 8년 정도 하고 다시
뉴욕에 돌아간게 이제 11년 좀
됐습니다
그러다 보니까 이제
뉴욕과 서울을 보고 가면서
여러가지 형태 부동산 딜을 좀 많이
접해 봤구요 지금도 여전히 액티브하게
활동하고 있습니다 지금 제가 일하고
있는 회사는
플래티넘 프로퍼티스라는 회사인데요
저희 에이전트 분들은 한 90분 정도
되시구요 그리고 저는 그 회사 안에서
코리아데스크를 맡고 있습니다 제일 첫
번째로 지금 제가 궁금한게 요즘에 좀
이렇게 뉴욕 상업용 부동산이 많이 좀
어렵다
얘기가 많은데
요즘에 좀 뉴욕 부동산 시장이 좀
어떤지 궁금하거든요
여러 매체에서 많은
이야기가 나오고 많이 접해 보신
분들은 잘 아시겠지만 사실
뉴욕도 미국에서의 오피스 시장이
상당히 좀 힘든 상황이에요 특히 이제
빈익빈 v플 현상이 좀 많아서 아주
좋은 오피스들은 그래도 이제 좋은
테넌트들을 계속 유지하고 그런 공실
없이 진행하는 부분이 있으신데 이제
그 중간에
a 중에서도 중요한 부분 뭐 b클래스
c클래스 이런 좀 안 좋은 오피스
시장은 공실이 절반이 너무
절반
현재는 어떤 얘기까지 많이 나오냐면
그런 오피스들을
맨하탄의 주거가 부족하니 주거로 좀
변환을 해서
용도변경을 해야 되지 않겠느냐 이런
이야기들도 많이 나올 정도로
오피스장을 많이 어렵고요 또 다른
섹터인 리테일 같은 경우에는
코로나가 종식된 후에
관광객이라든지 방문객들은 예전
수준으로 못 돌 정도로 많이
들어오셔서 많이 액티브 하긴 하지만
임대료 수준은 코로나 이전을 아직
회복을 못 했고요 다만 임대료가 가장
그래도 두드러지게 오르고 있는
섹터는 죽어 많이 오르고 있고요
근데 뭐 다 아시는 것처럼 이자율이
많이 올라가면서 주택의
판매되는 가격은
크게 변동이 없는 상황이에요 근데
이제 임대료는 계속 올라가다 보니까
어느 시점에서 이자율에 대한 하락이
있을거다라는 시점에는 사실이 주택에
가격 상승을 기대해 볼 수 있는
시점이기도 하고요
맨하탄은 코로나에 직격탄을 맞았다고
할 정도로 타격을 받은 도시이다
보니까
코로나 기간 동안 미국 전역에 뭐
코로나 이전과 비교했을 때 현재까지
한 30%, 40% 올라간 그런
상황에서
맨하튼은 아직도 10%
코로나 이전에 비교하면 10%
정도밖에 올라가지 않았기 때문에요
부분에 대한 어떤 키 맞추기도 일어날
수 있고 임대료가 한 가지 예를 들면
뭐 한 3.5 밀리언 되는
콘도의
코로나 이전 임대료가 한 달에 한 만
천불 정도 됐다고 하면 지금은
17000불
정도 총 올랐거든요
그러다 보니까이 임대료가 언론 부분에
있어서 이제
추후에 이자율이 하락되는 부분이
생긴다고 하면 가격이 올라갈 수 있는
부분이 충분히 좀 있다라고 보여지고
또 한 가지는
코로나 기간 동안 주거에 대한 공급이
많이
멈췄었어요
그러다 보니까 지금 상황에서는 사고자
하는 분들이
어떤 위치에 어떤 빌딩이 어떤 유닛을
골라서 할 수 있는 시장이긴 하지만
이게 조금 지나면 사실 좀 경쟁해야
되는 일상으로 할 수도 있을 것
같습니다 그래서 지금 어떻게 보면은
그 주거시장은 가격도 많이 오르고
임대료는 많이 올랐는데 아직 가격이
그렇게 좀 많이 오르지 않은 거고
근데 이제 지금 오피스라든지 좀
리테일 시장은 좀 많이 안 좋은 상황
리틀 하고 오피스하고 비교 굳이
비교하자면 오피스가
리틀보다 더 어려워요
아무래도 미국 전역에서 재택근무에
대한게 트렌드가 너무 확산이 되다
보니까 예전에 월 화 수 목 금
출근하던 거를 유연근무제를 통해서
3일만 나오라고 하는 회사도 많고
화수목이 출근하는게 어느 정도
보편화된 상황이다 보니까 오피스가 좀
많이 어려우면서
근데 그런 지금 오피스를 다 이제 좀
주거로 바꾸려는 움직임이 보이고 그
좀 호텔로 또 많이 바쁘더라고요
호텔보다는 아무래도 뭐 맨하탄 같은
경우에는
호텔이 지금 예전보다 많이 좋아지긴
했지만 아직 모자라고 있는 상황은
아니거든요 근데 주거 같은 경우에는
코로나 이전부터
맨하탄의 주거가 많이 부족하다 이런
부분들이 계속 이어져 왔기 때문에
뉴욕시 입장에서도 주민들을 위해서
계속 또 맨하탄이 가지고 있는 특성을
계속 유지하기 위해서는 주거에 대한
공급이 더 이루어져야 할 것 같습니다
근데 지금 오피스가 공실이 많다
보니까 그거를 이제 주거로 활용하려고
하는 그런 움직임들이 뭐
여러 곳에서 이루어지고 있죠 그래서
일단 뭐 뉴욕 부동산 시장에 대해서
좀 간단히 알아봤고 그것도 제가 이제
일전에 들었던 얘기 중에 되게
재밌었던 거 하나가 약간 유혹에 뭔가
변천사 그런 역사 같은 걸 되게 좀
재밌게
얘기해 주셔가지고 제가 좀 되게
신기했는데 오늘 그 얘기를 한번 좀
들어보도록 하겠습니다 그래서
지도를 보면서 최근에 아 뉴욕이
어떻게 발전을 했고 최근에는 좀
어디가 주로 사람들이 투자를 하는지
지도를 보면서 한번 좀 보도록
하겠습니다
면학단이 이렇게 보여지는
섬으로 보시면 될 것 같은데요
1700년대부터 이런
여러 수로를 통해서 많은 물자들이
동북으로 들어오기 위해서 이제
맨하탄을
통해서 많이 들어왔고요 지금 보시면
이렇게 대서양에서
쭉 들어와서 이쪽 이게 이제 허드슨
리본데요
맨하탄의 서쪽이죠이 허드슨리버가
쭉 이어져서 동부에 거의 캐나다
끝까지 이어져 있습니다
그러다 보니까이 수로를 이용하는 그런
여러 그런 화물선들이 많이 왕래를
했고 거기에 이제 가장 많은 화물들이
핸들링 되는 곳이
끝단이었죠 지금 이제
월스트리시는
금융지구인데 그런 부분이 계속 진행이
되면서 여기에 이제 많은
물자라든지 집중되면서 여기에 뉴욕
스타 익스체인지가 1700년 말쯤에
오픈을 했어요 그러다 보니까 그때부터
이쪽이 금융지구로써 어떤
뉴욕뿐만 아니라 미국
현재는 뭐 글로벌의 어떤 금융의
중심이 됐는데 여기는 사실은 주거에
대해서는 커다랗게 할애가 안 되어
있기 때문에
다음으로 보시면은 이쪽
센트럴파크
센트럴파크가
천 제 기억으론 1860년도
쯤에 완공이 돼서 그 이후로 플라자
호텔이 1890년대 정도에 오픈을
했어요 그 이후로는 이쪽
센트럴파크에 서쪽 동쪽
웨스트 어플리스트 그리고 이쪽
센트럴파크에 남단 쪽에서
고급 주거들이
생성이 됐고요 그래서 지금도 많은
밀집되어 있죠 그와 동시에 이제
동쪽으로 플라자 호텔에서
동쪽
맨하탄의 남쪽으로 약 47가에서
65가 사이에 아주 고급 오피스들이
밀집해서 들어오기 시작했어요 아주
유명한 법률회사라든지 큰 회사에 뭐
hq라든지 이쪽에 가보시면 정말 좋은
빌딩들이 많이 있고요 다들 아시는
것처럼
911 때이
파이낸셜 디스트릭트가 되게 타격을
받으면서 여기 입주했던 좀 커다란
금융회사들이 이쪽 플라자 디스트릭트로
많이
했죠 물론 다른 곳으로도 갔지만 여기
워낙에 고급 오피스들이 많이 있고 잘
개발이 되어 있다 보니까 이쪽도를
많이 왔는데 뭐 여기 로컬리 센터도
보이시죠
그런데 이게
요새는 이쪽 플라자 디스트릭트 어느
정도 시간이 지나면서 노후화되고
계속 개발되지가 있다 보니까 이전에
화물 운송수단으로
쓰여지던 그런 지역들 이쪽에 산업
인더스트리얼 지역이 서쪽으로 이렇게
쭉 있는데요
매스컴에도 많이 노출되니 허스슨야드
그리고 이쪽에 하이라인 연결된 공을
쭉
타고 내려오면서 이쪽에
첼시
트라이베카 이쪽으로 이제 좋은
오피스들이
계속 보게 됐어요 그러면서 또 고급
주거들도 이쪽으로 많이 공급이 됐죠
그러니까 좀
심플하게 얘기하면
오피스라든 이런 어떤 커다란 중요한
기능을
처음에는 이쪽 다운타운 파이낸스
디스트릭스 수행을 해 오다가 이쪽에
이제 미스트 쪽으로 갔고요 이게 한
4 50년 정도 진행이 됐고 그
다음에 최근에는
그런 많은 고급 인력들 뭐
아마존이라든지
페이스북이라든지 디즈니라든지 뭐 이런
좋은 회사들이 다 옮겨가다 보니까
이쪽으로도
고급 주고들이 이제 분양을 하고 새로
개발이 됐죠 그러다 보니까
JFK 공항에서
택시를 타고 오면은 리무진 택시
기사들이 우스갯소리로 그런 얘기들을
해요 이스트는 올드 모닝
웨스트는 유물
그리고 이제 많은
젊은 분들이라든지 그 도시에서 소비를
하는 분들이 예전에는이
프로젝트 스트리트의 좋은 오피스 지역
내에 아주 좋은 레스토랑이라 이런
것들이 아시는 것처럼 명품 거래도
이쪽에
5번과 메디슨의
좋은 오피스들이 옮겨오고 많은
유동량이 발생하면서 이쪽에 있는
기능들이 또 웨스트 다운타운을 많이
이전을 해 왔어요 그래서 지금은 사실
여기는 아무래도 서쪽 끝이고 좀
교통도 불편하고 하다 보니까 이쪽에서
일을 하시고 이쪽 여기가 이제 플랜
아이언 빌딩인데요 이쪽이 중심이
됐습니다 아 거기가요네 그리고 뭐
요새
한국 레스토랑들이 맨하탄에서 아주
선전을 하시는데 이쪽에 아주 파인
코리안 레스토랑들이 너무 너무 잘
되고 있어요 사실 이제 우리가
부동산을 얘기할 때는
지역을 얘기하고 빌딩을 얘기하고 그
빌딩 안에 유닛을 얘기하는데
지역적으로는 지금 어떤 그런 힘이
이쪽 웨스트 다운타운과 특히 이제
여기에서 중첩진 플레라이언 그리고
이쪽에서
맨하탄의
북쪽 남쪽 동쪽 서쪽으로 가기가 너무
편해요 그래서
지금 앞으로 투자를 하신다거나 뭐
매입을 생각하시는 분들 같은 경우에는
이쪽 지역을
눈여겨 보셔야 되지 않을까
그렇구나 저번에 갔을 때 하이라인
가서 일단 놀랐어요
사람도 너무 많고 걸어다니기 너무
좋다 그 전에 뉴욕 갔던게 한 7년
전 8년 전에는 없었거든요 있었는데
그렇게 활성화되지는 않았죠
최근에 갔을 때는 뭐 진짜 오피스도
굉장히 좀 큰 것들도 많고
죽어도 그렇고 그래서 되게 되게
놀래긴 했었거든요 저는 이쪽 분위기가
좀 더 좋은 거 같아요
근데 그 강변을 보고 있을 수 있는
그 위치가 사실은 예전에는 다 창고
화물 운송수단을 주차해야 되는 그런
산업지구였다 보니까
고기가 사실 개발자 입장에서는
개발하기가 그렇게
다른 지역의 빽빽하게 들어와 있는
곳보다는 수월하죠 그러니까
강변도 볼 수 있고 뭐 이런
여러 가지
인프라를 쉽게 늘 수 있는 웨스트
다운타운이 지금도 여전히 개발되고
있는 중입니다 그리고 또 제가 그때
뉴욕 가서 놀랬던 거리가 이제 그
흔히 말하는 이제 억만장자의
그래서 이렇게
밀리언 에어로가 센트럴파크 남단으로
이렇게 쭉 이어져 있는데요 미국은
이제
에어라이시라고 옆에 빌딩이 용적률을
사가지고 와서 내 빌딩이 얹을 수가
있어요
그러니까 그런 빌딩 많이 보셨을
거예요이 빌딩은 막
엄청 높은데 그 옆에 빌딩은 다 이제
에어라잇을 산다고 하는데
옆에 빌딩이 용적률을 사 와서 내
빌딩을 아주 높고 고급스럽게 짓는
거죠 이쪽이라서 보시면
정말 한 빌딩은 너무 높고 그 옆에
빌딩은 다 하나같이 다
작은 그래서 한 블록 전체에 사는
경우도 있고요
그러니까 이렇게 들어갈 수 있었던
거는 아까 말씀드렸듯이
센트럴파크를 기준으로 해서 이쪽에
고급 주거지역이라는 그런 아이덴티티가
너무 잘서 있기 때문에 또 명품
쇼핑도 할 수 있고
근데 요새는
신흥 부촌이라고 할 수 있는 부분이
아까 말씀드렸던 이런 쪽으로 좀
내려오고 있어요 그래서 뭐 다 아시는
아마존의
창업자 제프베이저스도 이쪽 플랜
아이언의 어떤 한 특정 콘도 빌딩의
상층부 5개층을 매입을 해서
본인이 직접 쓰고 있고 사실 어떻게
얘기하냐면 이쪽은 정말 레거시가 아주
강한 그런 부촌이고 여기 쪽은 이제
뭐 연예인분들이라든지 뭐 신흥
부자라든지 이런 분들이 이쪽에 힙한
문화
새로운 뭐 이런
인프라 이런 것들을 즐기기 위해서
웨스트 다운타운으로 많이들 내려오고
계십니다
마지막으로 출연하신 소감 사실 저도
길서 하나를 뭐 아주 자주 보진
않지만 가끔 이렇게 들어와서 보면
너무 말씀을 잘 하시고
시장에 대한 이해도 너무 좋으시고
어찌됐건 이렇게 또 소개해 주셔서
너무 감사하고요 이렇게 또 뉴욕에
대해서
정말 많은 이야기를 드릴 수 있는데요
정도까지 드릴 수 있는 기회가
주어져서 너무
감사합니다 아마 이제
뉴욕의 가면은 또 이제 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다